A combination of a TV star and TV character,
viewers welcomed Richard Harrison into their
homes over several hundred episodes.
His presence from the pawn shop and Pawn Stars
will be missed, and he's just as compelling
of a guy after he passed on.
Richard Harrison died on June 25th, 2018,
at the age of 77.
His son, Pawn Stars' Rick Harrison, confirmed
his father's passing via Instagram.
Underneath a stylish shot of the Old Man,
the younger Harrison wrote, in part,
"Richard Benjamin ‘The Old Man’ Harrison
passed away this morning surrounded by those
he loved.
He will be tremendously missed by our family,
the team at Gold & Silver Pawn and his many
fans the world over."
"There's a lot of memories here, and most
of those memories are with my father."
Later that day, Rick released another photo
of the Old Man this time as a young man to
Instagram, revealing in his caption that the
elder Harrison had, quote, "lost his long
battle with Parkinson's this morning."
Very few people outside of Harrison's inner
circle knew that he was sick, so his death
was a surprise to most as was the cause, a
devastating, progressive neurological condition.
Shortly after the Old Man died, Pawn Stars'
Austin "Chumlee" Russell" told TMZ,
"We had kind of had been preparing for it
for a while now, and I spent quite a bit of
time at his house this past week just knowing
that it could be coming soon and I wanted
to make sure I had plenty of time and memories
left with him while he was still here."
"This looks awesome, I'll go with you…
“No you won't, dumb-dumb, I'll go by myself."
The average viewer probably had no idea that
Harrison served in a variety of roles in the
U.S. Navy for more than 20 years.
As Rick recalled in his 2011 book License
to Pawn, the Old Man stole a car when he was
17, and a North Carolina judge gave him a
choice: enlist or go to jail.
Enlist he did, and after training, he shipped
out for tours on 2 different destroyers.
Over the following years, he won promotions
all the way up to first class petty officer
and retired from the Navy in 1979.
Harrison told Navy Times,
"Out of 20 years, I was deployed about 10.
The only reason I got out was that I had three
teenage boys, and the wife couldn't handle
them."
Harrison died a wealthy man at the age of
77.
He set up a will naming his wife and three
sons as his heirs and beneficiaries.
His trusted Pawn Stars partner, Rick, was
named the executor.
But according to legal papers published by
The Blast, Harrison filed an update in 2017
that he specified to make sure his son Christopher
didn't get a dime.
The Old Man wrote in the document,
"I would like to express my love and affection
for Christopher Keith Harrison, however, for
purposes of this Will, I have intentionally
and with full knowledge failed to provide
for him and his issue."
He gave no reason for the financial slight.
So what's next for Pawn Stars?
Just two days after Harrison's death, the
History Channel aired "A Treasure Remembered,"
a special tribute episode consisting of Harrison's
most memorable moments.
Not long after, the show went into production
for its 16th season.
Rick, Corey, and Chumlee all returned, and
no new hires were brought in to replace the
Old Man.
There has been one major change for Pawn Stars,
however.
When it returned after a long hiatus in January
2019, the show's episodes doubled in length,
expanding from a half-hour running time to
a full hour.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.